this is a story of automation and of the
people lost in the process
there was this accident a robot killed a
man it just didn't stop it's the very
first death in a driverless car any kind
of work that is fundamentally routine
and repetitive is gonna disappear
because AI is going to be everywhere we
don't want to replace a worker we want
to support ruckus we're talking about
machines now that are so cheap they do
exactly what a human does with less
money huge numbers of people feel that
they are being left behind they're right
they are the biggest danger that is the
discrediting of are empathetic responses
you could no longer tell
yeah
you